mein team heute abend gewalt gegen
polizeibeamte man muss sich vorstellen
in der letzten statistik die das
bundeskriminalamt veröffentlicht hat
reden wir über mehr als 90.000 meiner
kolleginnen und kollegen die im laufe
der letzten jahre opfer von gewalt
wurden das fängt an mit dem anspruch an
über den schlaf flaschenwurf bis hin zu
versuchten und vollendeten
tötungsdelikten jeder vierte kollege im
öffentlichen dienst jeder vierte
beschäftigte im öffentlichen dienst egal
ob bei der arbeitsagentur oder in der
kommune oder lehrer hat bereits gewalt
erfahren ich sage wer gewalt gegen
polizisten oder bediensteten in den im
öffentlichen dienst begeht der greift
den staat an und der greift diejenigen
an die das grundgesetz unsere republik
schützen hätten ihre prognose für die
gewalt weiter ansteigen glauben sie oder
er fährt erreicht das ziel wird
sicherlich also dass das dass das ziel
der gewalt wird sicherlich noch nicht
erreicht sein wir haben gerade diese
schwierigen lebensumstände beschrieben
die wir uns da ja im moment hinein
bewegen wenn die kollegin oder der
kollege beim
wohngeld in der wohngeldstelle einen
antrag ablehnen muss dann ist der oder
die wenigsten wenigen genauso gefährdet
wie der polizeibeamte der der versucht
eine demonstration zu schützen und das
recht auf versammlungsfreiheit
durchzusetzen polizisten sind immer ist
immer der verlängerte arm des staates
derjenigen die die gesetze in unserem
staat machen und das darf man eben nicht
vergessen und deshalb sage ich ja auch
mehr polizistinnen oder polizisten
angreift der ist hart zu bestrafen ist
hart zu bestrafen und vor allen dingen
auch zügig zu bestrafen ich glaube ein
großes problem ist
es ist die tatsache dass bis zu einem
prozess bis zu einem urteil so viel zeit
vergeht dass diejenigen die da gerade
beim nachhause fahren von dem
fußballspielen nach mit einer flasche
nach den polizeibeamten geschmissen
haben das gar nicht mehr wissen dass sie
dass da überhaupt getan
probleme mit gewalt gegenüber bürgern
oder gibt es während der korona panini
beispielsweise sind die auf der polizist
und bürger aneinandergeraten bei
demonstration beispielsweise also
polizisten und bürger geraten dann
aneinander
wenn die polizei eine angemeldete
demonstration
schützt das grundrecht auf
versammlungsfreiheit schützt
und jemand nicht nach den spielregeln
spielt bei der demonstration sondern aus
der demonstration heraus straftaten
begangen werden dann ist die polizei da
erstens mal die straftaten zu verhindern
und zweitens mal diejenigen zu schützen
die dort friedlich auf der straße
benutzen egal zu welchem anlass und egal
ob das der polizei schmeckt oder nicht
oder mir schmeckt oder nicht wir haben
auch castor-transporte begleitet
jahrelang nach gorleben und ich bin mir
sicher dass die vielen 1000
polizistinnen und polizisten eingesetzt
waren nicht alle 100 prozent
einverstanden waren mit der atompolitik
der bundesregierung das ist eben unser
job und da lege ich auch die hand für
ihn ins feuer dass meine kolleginnen
kollegen das so machen was
kontraproduktiv ist in so einer
situation sind gesetze wie
beispielsweise das landes anti
diskriminierungs gesetze in berlin was
die beweislastumkehr in sich trägt und
die polizistinnen und polizisten die
jemanden kontrollieren dann beweisen
müssen dass sie den nicht kontrolliert
haben vor dem rassistischen hintergrund
sondern einfach weil das polizeiliche
lagebild die kontrolle angezeigt hat
genau so hinderlich finde ich
irgendwelche studien die zum ziel haben
rechtsradikale
strukturen in der polizei in deutschland
aufzudecken also das gab es ja auch ein
paar fälle ich meine kann man ungefähr
dieser nsu 2.0 gab es da wo man mittels
hat das kam aus irgendwo ist nicht
pauschal um gottes willen nicht polizei
es wichtig ich aber trotzdem muss man ja
solche dinge auch ansprechen wenn es
aber etwas gibt es gab diesen realo fall
wo man auch nie wusste was ist deiner
gelaufen mit der anzügen der matratze
ich glaube solche dinge muss man schon
konsequent genau so konsequent wie alle
anderen straftaten verfolgt und will
wenn der beamten mit involviert sein
könnten muss man das auch zur anklage
bringen noch vor ihrer reise wert aber
von verdachtsfällen und das ist genau
das was ich kritisiere
es gilt überall die unschuldsvermutung
nun nicht bei der polizei bei mir nicht
also zunächst mal die unschuldsvermutung
nur nicht wenn wenn ein wissenschaftler
bei der deutschen hochschule der polizei
in münster studieren aufträge haben und
dann da jetzt erstmal eine befragung
machen bei den beiden polizeibeamten
heißt mega wo können sie gerne mal
recherchieren also die fragen die da
auftauchen bei dieser bei dieser studie
da stehen mir die haare zu berge und da
ist das ziel das ergebnis dieser studie
die betriebe hat eigentlich schon in der
überschrift beschrieben und das finde
ich absolut unangemessen der heutigen
zeit so geht man schlichtweg nicht mit
den polizistinnen polizisten um das
keine die politik denn tun um die
polizei besser zu schützen
sie kann vieles tun sie muss die
polizeibeamten auch schützen der staat
ist der dienstherr der
polizeibediensteten ob das nun beamte
sind oder angestellte wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass
ausrüstung gibt das also entsprechend
auch schutz gewährt wird wenn
gefahrenlagen bestehen nicht wenn also
gefahr besteht für landesbedienstete
oder eben für beamtinnen und beamten und
muss der staat da einstehen und er muss
natürlich auch konsequent vorgehen das
stimmt möglichst schnell und konsequent
wenn eben gewalt gegen beispielsweise
polizeibeamte ausgeübt wird eine
polizeibeamtin das ist absolut nicht
hinnehmbar
und das ist etwas wo wir auch sehr stark
darauf achten müssen 1 politik ist es
immer so dass man sich anschaut welche
straf- rahmen haben wir bei widerstand
gegen vollstreckungsbeamte auch wenn es
zu körperverletzungen in dem
zusammenhang kommt da ist einiges
geschehen in den letzten jahren
andererseits muss man eben auch sagen
wir müssen uns anschauen dass auch die
polizei rechtmäßig agieren muss das ist
ein anspruch den die bürgerinnen und
bürger haben sie haben auch den anspruch
dass das ein ein polizeiliches
fehlverhalten transparent aufgearbeitet
wird und da glaube ich können studien
nutzen an manchen stellen ich kenne
jetzt die münsteraner studien nicht das
sehen sie mir nach wir haben hier in
berlin eine tu studien die eben sich
auch anschauen wie wird polizeilich
zusammengearbeitet und gibt es da
bestimmte tendenzen die die
möglicherweise nicht nicht förderlich
sind zum gewissen chorgeist den wir
eigentlich nicht haben wollen wir wollen
eine transparente behörde wo man auch
mit offenem visier miteinander umgeht
und auch mit dem bürger umgeht das ist
dass das ist das ziel eine polizei sag
ich mal im besten sinne als freund und
helfer und eben aber auch eine polizei
die konsequent durchgreift und da gibt
es einen punkt wo man sagen muss wir
haben in der gesellschaft in teilen der
gesellschaft eben die tendenz und die
hat sich auch in den letzten jahren
stärker gezeigt
polizeiliche autorität nicht mehr so zu
achten wie das früher war ich glaube der
komponist zeit ist auch viel passiert
ich glaube da ist so ein bisschen viel
rutschen geraten gerade polizei
bevölkerung weil da auch glaube ich die
polizei seitens des staates an die
grenzen liegen geschoben wurde oder
gepusht wurde die bevölkerung natürlich
dementsprechend der situation geschuldet
einfach auch am limit war vom kopf her
von bap sich her und einfach da
unberechtigterweise die polizisten nach
vorne getrieben werden die bevölkerung
natürlich auch ihren unmut kund tut und
dann aufeinander knallen und dann dinge
passieren die eigentlich nicht hätten
passieren dürfen selbst bei
unbescholtenen bürgern gar nicht so
organisierte kriminalität sondern normal
otto normalbürger der dann auf einmal
sich damit irgendwie mit die polizisten
darum schlägt im schlimmsten fall was ja
auch nicht sein sollen darf